big premiere night for cbs this  wednesday love island usa is also back  love island baby won't you meet me by  the pool  last year we were in vegas and this time  we were actually on an island  um so it just brings this whole new  beautiful romantic sexy  energy to the show that it deserves 12  single guys and gals living in a  beautiful villa in hawaii  arielle vandenberg hosts and matthew  hoffman narrates while the love  and drama unfolds they are in swimsuits  the size  of my face mask like that is insane  tension brings the claws out so many  people love  your super fun commentary my first  moment  when i realized like oh people are just  recognizing  my voice i was interviewing kiki palmer  and she's like  you're the voice of love island and i  was like oh my god  you